hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time once again for our meetup
looking at map changes and updates to
fortnight chapter 2 season 1 and this
week we are bringing back the story
theories many of you have asked for we
have a bunch to get through so sit back
for 10 minutes lap code a tomorrow in
the store and let's go through the
latest update
[Music]
the biggest news this week is something
mind-blowing get your eyes around this
you can now hide in portaloos portable
toilets forgive me if this has always
been here I can't say I've ever tried to
jump in a toilet until this week I
remember trying this in season X but it
wasn't possible so now it is it's
beautiful and this will be your meme
tactic for the week to ambush someone
from the plastic palace why does it look
so much better when it's a stormtrooper
okay so I'm sure you've noticed the
animation is absolutely dreadful
especially when it's in replay theater
it's sort of nightmare fuel isn't it I'm
sure they'll fix that it's not that bad
in-game when you're playing I promise I
come to think of it mr. stormtrooper I
think you're using that toilet
incorrectly well speaking of the plastic
man with no aim there was a mini Star
Wars crossover this week thanks to
everyone who used my code when grabbing
the stormtrooper much appreciated in the
skies above we could make out the shape
of something it was a Star Destroyer
it's only a small touch I know but don't
you think things like this make this
game really special and in homage to
Star Wars I'll be wearing this skin all
video and one thing we must do
immediately is test if our aim has
improved since becoming a stormtrooper
let's do this
[Music]
um can can I blame bloom in fact cells
are Nolan I've got an idea 800 percent
accuracy their stormtrooper for life
whilst looking around the island this
week I've seen many areas of random
snowfall I know this already exists in
the snowy biomes but I also saw this at
sweaty sands and even riskier eels maybe
it's a glitch in the matrix or maybe
Christmas is on the way and we all love
three holes sorry I misread that
Christmas is on the way hohoho future
YouTube there is also evidence of
Christmases arrival down by the docks
with storage units filled with reindeer
ready for the festivities to begin also
why are you here you can find items that
changed West world last season do you
remember the multiple TVs and the chairs
they can be found in this location and
this all could link to the happenings
over at retail row the Halloween
decorations have finally left and the
shop is now ready for new tenants to
sign their contract so I'm expecting a
Christmas star here and if we look
outside in the car park it's been
cordoned off there's a fence now around
it and last time this happened it became
a Christmas tree here so maybe another
Christmas tree or what about some sort
of Santa's grotto time will tell anyway
you like Christmas right you're not
claustrophobic are you
I like Crimbo I get all sentiment Santa
mental it doesn't work that one does it
do you get what I was trying it doesn't
matter
early I'll leave for the air Christmas
puns until next month and that's it's no
joke
[Music]
another phenomenon happened this week at
risky reels the screen came alive I
couldn't wait to see it I jumped right
in I had to see this with my own eyes
and this was my view
remember the unbolting event no neither
do I because it never actually happened
for me so I'm scared to death anyway
here's a few shots of what it looked
like to other people it was only a test
but I still wanted to see it so do me a
favor in the comments if you would did
you see the cinema screen in action i
play on EU and i saw nothing
nada nowt and speaking of phenomenons
have you heard about the chapter one
ghost stuck in the world it's a fable
I've been trying to spot this for the
last 10 days supposedly if you spend
enough time down by Camp Cod and the
gravestones there a ghost can be spotted
I stood here for 15 games in a row and
died repeatedly to the storm and i saw
absolutely nothing but thanks to duty
gameplays we have evidence is this real
I can't be sure so I went back in and my
watch began I was determined I was going
to find this spooky bugger and confirm
this myth
[Music]
so the locker received an update we can
now search by keyword so what did we all
do instantly right the seven in the
search bar and this is what happened
are these really four of the seven that
formed the black hole well maybe yeah
they could be but actually we just
really searched up the word though so
maybe don't take this as a big deal
well not yet anyway but speaking of the
seven I should include them in today's
story theory don't you think other
pieces of news this week we now have
patch notes again huzzah
it's pretty underwhelming but they at
least are back which includes DirectX
support for you people on PC so at least
you guys will have a stable frame rates
unlike us on the crippling consoles
happy days and some terrible news now
chapter one of season two is going to
continue way into February 20 2002
helped break this up though we're going
to have a fortnight fortnight 14 days of
Christmas
shenanigans let's hope they are great
updates because watching this game die
slowly is absolutely killing the inside
like I've taken anymore nothing to
report here at bunker watch this week we
had fun though staring at this door for
four hours it's like therapy time for
our discard so guys you said you wanted
story theories to return with map update
videos so your wish is my command
this week's theory is about a time
vortex and it sets the scene for future
weeks so hit the dramatic music and
let's put a narrative to all the actions
in Chapter two
it seems like forever ago we saw the
island we inhabited for two years
destroyed by the event absol in aimed
the end the visitor finally destroyed
the nexus point to dismantle this cycle
in time we'd be repeating but by doing
this another anomaly occurred a black
hole
[Music]
without warning we were sucked through
time and space and into the abyss for
days we watched the black hole wondering
if we'd ever come through to the other
side but this is where science teaches
us a black hole bends time making a few
seconds feel like a decade making two
days be like forever the things dragged
through the black hole and me a few
seconds before us would actually arrive
in the next dimension days weeks months
and even years prior to the rest of us
so when our moment came and we finally
ripped through to the next world we had
already missed so much we missed out on
the island being built the civilization
growing many small things too like the
food fight mascots they landed before
our arrival and sat dormant rotting away
decomposing the cube we called Kevin
looks to have become a nuclear power
plant overnight when in reality it had
been here for years before us how did
all the chapter 1 memorabilia get here
in reality someone has been collecting
this for months and months we just
weren't here to see it and when we
finally arrived the world was already
complete
of course the story like this isn't all
about good times oh no there's something
more sinister at work here the bridge of
the seven made is seemingly an
alternative dimension but it's also a
bridge to other dimensions like a
multiverse before we got here there was
a team that landed the first team to
land here in a new world were aboard the
ego
24:05 12 d s remember that code it's
important to the story just not this
week the survivors are from another
island just like our own but their
reality branched from ours when we left
air travel behind to build mechs in
their world they made planes big enough
to carry entire squads but nothing
prepared the ego team for the black hole
forcing them to crash-land here as the
first settlers here they had much to do
breaking out of their ruins and building
a new future for their passengers first
setting up a makeshift camp as the
week's went by the ego's expanded
utilizing their knowledge of slurp
technology to build super soldiers and
harnessing having the cube to create
energy sources but this was their
undoing we already know about the dark
matter the cube is possessed by an evil
spirit which creates negative versions
of anyone who makes contact with it it
was only a matter of time until the cube
created alternative versions of the egos
leading to their first encounter
together red and blue complete equals in
every way but the alternate version had
one key difference evil in the first
encounter the egos somehow survived but
this is only the beginning of the story
the egos versus the alters in a battle
to decide the future of our new home so
now as we drop in it's time for us to
make a choice which side do we fight for
the light the blue the dark the
[Music]
thank you very much for your time as
always here is the legend roll call
thank you if you've use my code I really
appreciate it like always I'm so far
behind on my DMS but I will get to you
you have my word
thanks for your time it's been a
pleasure I am Adam from PlayStation
granade see you soon
[Music]
you